[Music]
magnificent flight around the world by
way of the equator miss Amelia Earhart
was lost in mid of the disappearance of
aviator Amelia Earhart 81 years ago
remains one of the greatest unsolved
mysteries in American history but this
week researchers revealed a new clue
that may shed light on what happened to
Earhart and her navigator Fred Noonan as
they tried to circle the globe everybody
happy ending to the search because
Amelia was out there calling for help
and her calls were being hurt Ric
Gillespie who has researched Earhart's
doomed flight for 30 years says he has
proof Earhart crash-landed on a remote
South Pacific island about two thousand
miles from Hawaii and that she called
for help
for nearly a week before her plane was
swept out to sea Gillespie is located
documentation of distress signals sent
in the days after Earhart's
disappearance prompting the Navy to
launch a rescue mission and it took a
week to get there by which time the
radio signals had stopped and when the
planes flew over the island they didn't
see an airplane now the airplanes
manufacturer Lockheed had said that if
you're hearing calls from this airplane
it it's not floating around in the water
because the radios would be wet wouldn't
work the airplane is on land and able to
run an engine to recharge the battery so
it's not at wheels she's made a safe
landing someplace Gillespie says the
calls weren't just heard by the Navy but
also by dozens of people who
unexpectedly picked up Earhart's
transmissions on their radios thousands
of miles away these are just regular
people who had a commercial radio set
that they listened to a little orphan
Annie on but it also had a shortwave
band where they could tune in foreign
stations reports of people hearing calls
for help or documented in places like
Florida Iowa and Texas one woman in
Canada reported hearing a voice saying
we have taken in water we can't hold on
much longer then suddenly they're
hearing miliary call for help and
they're astonished Gillespie's
organization the international group for
historic aircraft recovery has also
found forensic evidence that bones found
on the island are almost certainly
Earhart's and while the official stance
is that
Earhart and Noonan were lost at sea
Gillespie says the radio evidence only
strengthens his theory that they
survived the initial landing this case
is closed
he believes clothes there are still some
competing theories out there but can you
imagine being in Iowa and I did know I
think people heard those calls hands and
needles about it and people are still so
fascinated by Wright he's working on it
30 years